vor einiger Zeit habe ich ein Video
hochgeladen indem ich drei Tage
htereinander jeden Tag den günstigsten
Flug gebucht habe es gibt nämlich eine
App mit der man sich von jedem Ort auf
der Welt den günstigsten Flug anzeigen
lassen kann zusammen mit einem Kollegen
habe ich mich auf die Reise gemacht und
wir haben genau das umgesetzt als
kleines Extra es muss jeden Tag in ein
neues Land gehen und damit einen
wunderschönen guten Mittag aus meinem
Büro wir sind gerade noch zu Hause Leute
das nächste richtig geile Projekt steh
an ich glaube es wird richtig fett die
nächsten vier Tage werden wir einiges
erleben ich habe das ganze ja schon mal
gemacht damals mit einem anderen
Kollegen Noel schöne Grüße und heute
startet die Reise noch mal mit
Tristan grüß dich falls ihr euch
erinnert wir waren auch in Thailand
zusammen unterwegs und er kommt spontan
mit ist eigentlich immer ganz geil für
mich weil dann bin ich nicht die ganze
Zeit alleine es steht auf jeden Fall an
jeden Tag den günstigsten Flug suchen
und buchen für insgesamt vier Tage und
diesmal ein bisschen anders ihr habt's
auch zahlreich kommentiert beim letzten
Mal waren wir wirklich fast eigentlich
nur in Spanien und bei diesem Video
möchte ich das so umsetzen dass wir
wirklich jeden Tag in ein anderes Land
fliegen als ich heute morgen
aufgestanden bin habe ich den ersten
Flug für heute schon gebucht Blend euch
hier mal ein das günstigste war sadar
für insgesamt jetzt glaube ich 52 € also
26 € pro Person sadar habe ich vorher
eigentlich noch nie gehört das ist
irgendwas in Kroatien natürlich wieder
mit Skyscanner da gibt's diese Funktion
dass man so günstige Reiseziele
entdecken kann jeden Tag überall hin von
jedem Ort auf der Welt eigentlich wir
fliegen wieder von Köln habe ich glaube
ich schon gesagt das wird jetzt das
erste Ziel und wenn wir da angekommen
sind schauen wir dann wo es morgen
hingeht und so dann halt jeden Tag
weiter und ich glaube es wird echt cool
weil beim letzten Mal hatten wir richtig
viel Spaß und ich hoffe du hast richtig
Bock mitgebracht einiges einiges so wir
hatten gerade schon das erste Problem
und zwar können wir natürlich kein
handgepäckskoffer mitnehmen weil wir
jeden Tag nur Rucksack dabei haben
dürfen gerade bei diesen billig Airlines
gibt's sonst immer Probleme jetzt haben
wir aber alles hier in diesem
wunderschönen ister für Rucksack keine
Ahnung auf geht's so Leute angekommen in
Köln am Flughafen wir haben jetzt 15:30
Uhr oder 15:15 Uhr unser Flug geht um
16:45 Uhr das heißt jetzt erstmal in
Ruhe Einchecken dann noch was essen und
dann geht's los nach Kroatien ich bin
mal gespannt ich war noch nie in meinem
Leben in Kroatien falsche rolltrep warte
mal wir sind bei Terminal 2 erster Flug
ist nämlich ry Air eigentlich ist ryir
immer von Terminal 2 geflogen in Köln
aber anscheinend hat sich das geändert
das wäre auch mal eine Video der einfach
hier hinlad schon irgendwas buen Last
Minute ma ich irgendwann bestimmt auch
Mali ganz schön teuer Ägypten 3000er SP
Thailand W man nicht wieder nach
Thailand riss ich bin kurz einal nach
vorne gehopst und ich bin jetzt gerade
auch schon da und vor mir ist wirklich
eine wunderschöne Aussicht aber bleibt
einfach noch ein bisschen dran das
werdet ihr gleich sowieso sehen und mich
erreichen wirklich nach wie vor oft
Nachrichten wann denn endlich monopoli
reiseedition Folge 6 online kommt gerade
drhen wir ein anderes Video aber nicht
traurig sein weil ich habe da eine gute
Lösung für euch man muss ja einfach
festhalten dass klassische monopoi ist
wirklich ein richtig geiles Brettspiel
und ich denke eigentlich fast jeder von
uns ist damit groß geworden und ab
sofort gibt es Monopoly go als App im
Appstore und Play Store für jeden zum
Download und das ist kostenlos also eine
absolut neue und innovative Variante um
monopoi online gegen Freunde von euch
auf der ganzen Welt zu spielen die ich
sag mal klassischen Bausteine von
monopoli sind auf jeden Fall weiterhin
enthalten aber es gibt auch jede Menge
neue Features die sich auf jeden Fall
Lohn zu entdecken für mich auf meinen
Reisen auch ein super Zeitvertreib wenn
man irgendwo wartet ein bisschen
Monopoly go schadet nie ihr könnt eure
eigenen Städte bauen es ist wirklich
sehr nice und Tristan hat sich es auch
schon gedownloadet also worauf wartest
du noch hol dir Monopoly go und keine
Sorge monopoli reiseedition Folge 6
kommt bald und jetzt machen wir weiter
mit dem Video also genau hier hat's mit
Noel auch gestartet da war hier nur ein
bisschen mehr los glaube ich Lanzerote
nach Lanzerote ging's da erstmal Leute
das war auch eigentlich so das erste
Reisevideo von mir wo ich dieses Projekt
halt schon mal umgesetzt habe und das
ist ja so müsste ungefähr 7 Monate her
sein da ging das so los und jetzt bin
ich richtig drin so Abflüge haben wir
hier dann schon da zada 16:40 B31
tada so Security Check haben wir
geschafft jetzt geht's erstmal in der
Lounge was essen ich muss sagen ich bin
jetzt auch ewig nicht von Köln
ausgeflogen das heißt es wird das erste
mal hier in der Lounge in loue
Lounge ich glaube das WD hier neu
gemacht die
loue also hier ist es sogar zwei stöckig
unten gibt's nur Getränke und oben
gibt's auch essen ich bin echt mal
gespannt erster Eindruck durchweg
positiv ist ja eine priority Pass Lounge
also hier kann man jetzt nicht so die
mega Auswahl erwarten aber mal
schauen so dann lass ich dir mal
schmecken der ist mit Schuss jetzt ne
mit Schuss der ist mit mit Jacky drin
also eine Sache die uns hier aufgefallen
ist hier sind super viele am Saufen um
diese Uhrzeit schon wir haben gerade mal
16 Uhr irgendwie muss man uns ja
aushalten ne das sieht ja richtig
gmackhaft aus was du da machst muss ja
bisschen Geschmack dran ne das war
gerade echt ein bisschen sehr knapp also
ich bin froh dass die uns no mitnehmen
weil bei reer ist das immer so ein
bisschen kritisch in der Lounge da stand
nämlich noch kein Boarding und
eigentlich steht da immer Boarding wenn
es losgeht das wde dort einfach nicht
angezeigt und das war schon längst
Boarding hallo Reihe
8 Reihe 8 du hast
anderi so Leute los geht's frag mich
gerade was ist da für eine Baustelle der
Boden sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus
was machen die da könnt ja mal
kommentieren wenn ihr es wisst
also ich muss sagen ich bin echt
beeindruckt von diesen ganzen Inseln da
wie gesagt ich war noch nie in Kroatien
und das sieht wirklich verdammt geil aus
elich für
[Musik]
Griechenland
also ich finde hier riecht irgendwie wie
in Spanien im Urlaub so ist
wahrscheinlich auch einen Breitengrad ne
schön aber ey du warst ja noch gar nicht
hier nee also erster Eindruck Leute
richtig geil J aber nee wir sind gar
nicht in Griechenland macht nich also so
viele Geldautomaten habe ich noch nie
auf einem Haufen gesehen von allen
verschiedenen Anbietern das heißt man
kann vermutlich die Taxen jetzt nicht
mit Karte bezahlen sonst würden die hier
glaube ich nicht stehen sieht so aus
ne
okay
D
PR
Taxi how
K
15 taxom
yes not
not50
kom km
Taximeter also der wollte von uns jetzt
50 € haben ich habe jetzt noch mal zum
Glück kurz
alles sehr spanisch V 18 € Alter überall
muss du aufpassen das ist unglaublich
oder also ich muss sagen ich finde das
schon super kriminell eigentlich weil da
steht ja sogar das Taxi mit dem Logo und
so man denkt eigentlich bei sowas wird
man nicht abgezogen fix PR over
Taxometer over fix PR coming Gerät sind
bei achtung AbZ mit Peter das darf nicht
wahr sein die
PEN immerin gibt
Kaufland
oh
cool so Leute angekommen direkt am
Wasser ey geil sieht doch schon schön
aus das ist unsere erste Unterkunft das
ist jetzt natürlich kein Hotel oder so
sondern eher so ein Apartment aber halt
direkt am Wasser wir haben es ins
Apartment geschafft erste Eindruck ist
auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt hat jetzt
68 € pro nach gekostet für zwei also 34
€ pro Person so gesehen und wir haben ja
eigentlich alles was man braucht was wir
auch eigentlich gar nicht brauchen eine
Küche eigentlich bräuchten wir nur zwei
Betten hier haben wir jetzt ein Bett das
ist unser Schlafzimmer da schlafen wir
heute Sofa und wir haben wir noch das
Badezimmer ja wir gehen jetzt gleich
direkt hier in der Altstadt in sadar die
soll wohl sehr sehr schön sein der uber
driver hat uns gerade schon erzählt dass
hier irgendwie fast gar nichts mehr los
ist aber wir schauen mal und ich werde
auch denke ich heute Abend schon
abchecken wo es dann morgen hingeht oder
wo es dann weiterhing geht aber jetzt
gleich erstmal in der Stadt was essen
ich habe Bock ich freue mich auf
Kroatien wie gesagt erste Mal hier bis
gleich so wir sind unterwegs ich habe
meine GoPro dabei das ist eigentlich ein
ziemliger life changer für mich weil
sonst war immer mit Handy aber GoPro ist
noch einfacher wir laufen jetzt gerade
am en langang und da vorne wir haben ja
noch so eine Map bekommen vom
Hotelinhaber da vorne kommt jetzt gleich
so ein Steg und da ist dann wohl jemand
mit dem Boot der bringt uns dann in die
Altstadt dann geht's ins Restaurant und
mal gucken was wir sonst noch so machen
auf was hast du Bock vielleicht finden
wir ja noch in der Disse und was
natürlich ein bisschen schade ist ist
dass es jetzt schon so dunkel ist hier
geht die Sonne ja noch eher unter als in
Deutschland wir sind halt erst so um
kurz vor 6:30 Uhr gelandet und ja dann
war es schon fast dunkel na ja morgen
ist ja auch noch ein Tag okay wir sind
jetzt hier am richtigen Hafen
anscheinend hier liegen auf jeden Fall
einige fette Boote und da vorne ist
jetzt wohl jemand mit so einem kleinen
Boot der uns dann da hinten Leuchtet
also das ist die Old Town schon einmal
darüber fährt das ist auch gar nicht
weit bin echt mal gespannt ob das jetzt
funktioniert du hast noch Bargeld weil
der wird keine Karte nehmen
nicht was ist das
denn sind 2 € komm das wird schon
klappen
hallo
much okay
perfect
nice komm
so jetzt sind wir gleich schon drüben
fast cool so auf der anderen Seite
angekommen jetzt geht's was essen wir
sind jetzt hier in der Altstadt wo
eigentlich so ja die meisten Touristen
rumlaufen sollten denke ich mal und wenn
man sich hier so umschaut sind wir
eigentlich fast die einzigen aber ist
halt auf season jetzt bin ich echt mal
gespannt um die Ecke weil man sagt ja
immer kroatische Städte Dörfer sind
super schön ja verkehrt a schau nicht ne
sollen wir hier durchgehen oder willst
Du hier jetzt erst was essen oder willst
hier trinken hier haben wir jetzt die
Kirche also ich bin wirklich sehr sehr
beeindruckt von der Stadt oder die
Altstadt hier vor allem auch wie sauber
das alles ist mach mal das Geräusch wie
naturenhalle
warte hier wird immer richtig drüber
poliert über den Boden ich brauch jetzt
aber ganz dring was zu essen ey so wir
haben glau ich ein nices Restaurant
gefunden für mich gibt's auf jeden Fall
schon mal das craft local beer ist ja
ganz klar so sieht das hier aus under
schönen Fußgängerzone und Essen schauen
wir noch so essen ist da für mich gibt's
Nudeln mit so ein bisschen beef hat auch
so Nockis aber die sind schwar hat das
hier ist das Local plavusa Leute auch S
bin mal
[Musik]
gespannt ja ist okay jetzt bin ich froh
dass ist mein erstes richtiges Essen
heute und danach bin ich glaube ich auch
wieder bisschen fitter so Leute ich habe
gerade schon mal geguckt wo wir dann
morgen hinfliegen weil ich find es immer
ganz gut wenn ich den Plan schon habe
ihr könnt jetzt hier sehen hier oben
haben wir sadar drin und dann gibt man
hier alle Orte ein ne so wir haben jetzt
morgen den 12 ach so wir sind zu zweit
und dann sucht er hier und wir können
natürlich zurück nach Deutschland
fliegen aber da kommen wir her das zählt
nicht weil wir wollen ja jeden Tag ein
neues Land und dann haben wir hier
weiter Griechenland dann ist
Thessaloniki hier das günstigste 7 € und
hier ist dann das Problem oder was heißt
Problem aber wir müssen dann in Krakau
zwischenlanden aber ja gut dann sind wir
halt einen Tag in Krakau und fliegen
dann am nächsten Tag weiter das heißt
ich buche jetzt eigentlich zwei Flüge in
einem aber ist ja nicht schlimm so Leute
aufgegessen haben wir jetzt sind wir
hier noch an einem anderen Spot sehr
sehr nice schöne Brücke schön beleuchtet
was machen wir jetzt noch wir gehen in
irgendeine Bar gucken mal ob da was geht
aber ich denke den das wird heute nicht
so lange gehen weil hier eigentlich
nichts los ist oder halt nicht so viel
so jetzt gibt erstmal noch ein
kroatisches Eis lecker ist es aber die
Kugeln wurden eher nebeneinander
positioniert übereinander
junge oh hier bisschen Karaoke also das
war bis jetzt auf jeden Fall der beste
Spot hier von der Stimmung her wie
verrückt hier wird wirklich nachts
einfach der Boden gewischt in sad das
gibt ja gar nicht guck mal wir W hier
fast ausgerutscht das jetzt ganz schön
rutschig
ich würde gerne mal so ein Auto sehen
was hier sauber macht wir schauen uns
jetzt auf jeden Fall diesen einzigen
Club an der hier auf hat der heißt
irgendwie opra Club nur ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe irgendwie die
Befürchtung dass bei google steht dass
er auf hat aber in echt hat er zu weil
ich würde mich echt ein bisschen wundern
wenn jetzt hier ein Club plötzlich
aufhätte weil hier ist wirklich alles
tot Vorsicht die war eben sehr aggressiv
als ich die zum ersten Mal gesehen habe
aber du hast es ja mit Tieren was sagst
du zu ihrem
schurb also das da oben ist schon
eigentlich nicht der muss da ganz hinten
sein wobei die haben richtig Spaß
ne ich bin mal gespannt wie das hier so
im Hellen aussieht aber ja kann sich
sehen lassen ne so wir sind da hier ist
der opra Club leider sieht es schon so
aus wie ich befürchtet habe und zwar
hier ist irgendwie nichts los und ich
glaube hier wird heute auch nichts mehr
los sein ja schade
eigentlich
Ton cl
to not ja was soll wir machen sad ist
tot wir haben jetzt ja noch viele Tage
vor uns die werden auch noch hart machen
heute erstmal langsam war TR meinte er
WD sich trauen auf se Boot zu springenri
von Strafe ach hier ist doch gar
keiner
ja und damit einen wunderschönen guten
Morgen aus sada in Kroatien wir sind
gerade aufgestanden es ist auch gar
nicht mehr so früh ich muss
ehrlicherweise sagen die Nacht war echt
nicht gut also wir haben beide nicht gut
geschlafen keine Ahnung woran es lag ich
war 54 000 Mal wach und bin auch
wirklich erst um 6 Uhr so richtig
eingepennt obwohl ich schon um 1 Uhr im
Bett lag wir gehen jetzt erstmal zum
Supermarkt Frühstück holen und dann
schauen wir mal was wir heute so machen
heute Nacht ist aber schon mal da vorne
eine Yacht angekommen ist auf jeden Fall
Fett ich finde das hier ganz interessant
dass die Straße so direkt am Wasser ist
ne weil wenn hier mal ein Unfall
passiert fallen die Autos ja rein warte
mal das soll jetzt hier der Supermarkt
sein wobei hier kannst ja auch Boxen
gehen jetzt bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt ob das Ding hier aufh irgendwie
sieht das ist nicht so einladend aus
oder wir sind halt einfach auf der
falschen Seite das kann ja auch sein ach
ja ja okay ne jetzt geht's ja
interessant so jetzt ist die Frage was
holen wir uns zum Frühstück hatten wir
be uns ein Sandwich Maker gibt auch so
ja ein Cappuccino würde ich nehmen oh
toastfot ist hier aber teuer 3 €
eingekauft haben wir irgendwie ist es
ein bisschen komisch hier in S also klar
gerade ist total Offseason keine Touris
und alles aber laut Google haben die
hier wohl 150.000 Einwohner und es ist
eigentlich alles komplett wie leer
also egal wo man lang geht gich
hier stehen und so aber diese Gebäude
sehen alle total leer aus vielleicht
sind das alles irgendwelche
Ferienwohnung oder keine Ahnung aber
irgendwie wirkt das hier ein bisschen
ausgestorben haben wir gestern Abend
auch schon gedacht also an die Leute die
hier öfter hinfahren ich bin gespannt
auf eure Kommis so wäre ich jetzt
Instagram influencerin würde ich sagen
breakfast with a view bin ich aber zum
Glück nicht aber ist trotzdem schön auch
wenn die Sandwiches ein bisschen tot
gesandwicht
aussehen so bevor es gleich weiter nach
Krakau geht wollen wir erstmal ein
bisschen pfanschen gehen weil wir müssen
ja wenigstens noch einmal hier ins
Mittelmeer springen jetzt ma ma uns
erstmal richtig gemütlich mit
uns oh war das mal ein
Vogel war eine Möwe ne Alter die liegt
da noch nicht so lange glaube ich wir
können ja auf den Stein und dann
springen wir von da rein ich glaube der
offizielle Strand den wir jetzt online
gefunden haben war das hier nicht aber
egal zack ist aber ganz schön rutschig
kannst du mir die mal eben zuwerfen also
von den Stränden her gefällt mir Spanien
besser eine reicht ja oder wenn wir
jeder eine
[Musik]
haben Leute geile Temperatur tolles
Wetter wir sind zw irgendwie die
einzigen hier mehr aber fand's gut doch
hat was ne es jetzt halt auch la season
ne leute das ist wirklich so dumm ich
checke jetzt gerade ein für unseren
nächsten Flug und sobald man R Air nicht
über die rir Seite Bucht kommt immer so
eine Fehlermeldung dass man über so ein
nicht authentifiziertes Buchungsportal
gebucht hat und da muss man sich immer
noch extra verifizieren das kostet Hal
immer 59 Cent weil wir brauchen ja
unsere Tickets heute es geht natürlich
auch gratis aber da muss man 7 Tage
warten das war gestern auch schon so als
ich eingecheckt habe und jetzt muss ich
es einfach wieder machen also es wirkt
immer alles ganz entspannend aber
manchmal ist es auch echt nervig
Zahlungsdetails angeben dann muss ich
mein Ausweis gleich hochladen dann noch
ein selfie von mir machen und irgendwann
kann ich dann Einschecken und jetzt muss
ich die gleiche Scheiße noch mal machen
weil wir ein Kraker umstcken es ist zum
kotzen
wirklich so Leute ausgecheckt haben wir
es ist jetzt ungefähr 17 Uhr und wir
gehen jetzt einmal hier in die Altstadt
wo wir auch gestern Abend schon waren um
noch eine Kleinigkeit zu essen und dann
geht's auch schon zum Flughafen unser
Flug nach Krakau ist um 22:10 Uhr also 5
Stunden Zeit haben wir noch ich will
zwischendurch noch einmal kurz mir eine
neue Hose kaufen weil ich habe kaum noch
Sachen und in Krakau ist es natürlich
ein bisschen kälter als hier aber jetzt
erstmal was essen und wir sehen uns dann
denke ich gleich wieder wenn es heißt
tschüss kroat und ab nach Polen noch ein
kurzen zwischensto hier eingelegt bei
wunderburger in sadar muss sagen optisch
geil aber ich habe auch schon viele
optische Burger dann probiert und die
waren nicht so gut wie ich dachte bin
mal gespannt das Brötchen ist sehr
intensiv und ziemlich süß finde ich
schaut mal
Leute wir haben zwei pties übereinander
die sind beide gesmasht und ich bin ja
eh großer smashburger Fan schon nicht
verkehrt also überzeugt mich 8,2 von so
gucken wir uns hier noch einmal kurz das
schöne Meer von Kroatien an und dann
sind wir wieder
[Musik]
Weg wir gehen jetzt kurz noch hier in
dieses Shoppingcenter und ich hole noch
ein paar Klamotten weil irgendwie bin
ich wieder mit viel zu wenig losgefahren
das Problem habe ich immer ich pack 5
Minuten vorher bevor der Flug geht
gefühlt und dann frage ich mich wo
eigentlich meine Unterhosen waren oder
meine Socken weil die fehlen warum ist
das Licht in so zumkleiden immer so
bodenlos ich sehe aus wie und irgendwie
denke ich auch ich bin viel dicker
geworden weil passen diese Hosen gar
nicht mehr richtig muss ich wohl noch
mal größer nehmen auf jeden Fall nehme
ich diese Hose und diesen Pulli und ich
glaube dann bin ich gut für Krakau
aufgestellt mittlerweile angekommen in
sad am Flughafen wir sind jetzt in der
nächsten Lounge und das ist wirklich mit
Abstand die kleinste Lounge die ich hier
in meinem Leben gesehen
[Musik]
habe also hier läuft auf jeden Fall
alles ein bisschen anders ab als in
Deutschland alle Leute stehen plötzlich
vorm Flugzeug na ja wir haben jetzt auch
schon 22 Uhr und wir werden auch erst um
23:40 Uhr Krakau sein das heißt ziemlich
spät aber das hält uns natürlich nicht
davon ab heute Abend trotzdem noch
irgendwas zu erleben also wir hoffen mal
ich war ja auch noch nie in Krakau ich
war er ein einziges Mal in Polen das war
auch für ein Youtube Video deswegen
freue ich mich weil Polen war echt geil
krakau ist auch eine richtig nice Stadt
laut Internet sieht auch cool aus ich
bin
gespannt ich war noch nie erst aus dem
Flugzeug okay angekommen Krakau hier ist
es auf jeden Fall deutlich kälter als
eben noch in Kroatien schaut mal hier le
wird gerufen du gehörst zu unseren am
besten bewerteten Fahrgästen das spricht
doch für mich oder immer freundlich auf
Reisen und zu vollkommen gut
erzogen das MS unser h
seinkmen
Hall so Hotel eingecheckt erstm leckeren
Apfel schon 12 Uhr schon bisschen spät
ne manchmal zu viel high auch nicht gut
also dieses ständige Reisen ist schon
manchmal anstränkt wir haben ger mal Tag
zi ich habe gerade so eine kleine
Downphase aber wir gehen jetzt direkt
los oder umziehen so ich habe mich kurz
umgezogen wir sind jetzt hier auf dem
Bett und ich will jetzt hier noch in
city wir haben :30r
und nee haben wir nicht um 5 Uhr ist
Schicht im Schacht das ist jetzt der
Plan
TR Kaffee eine Frage wollt du noch
stellen wie hat er eentlich s gefallen
also mir persönlich reicht jetzt auch
erstmal Party das war jetzt ohne Witz
also fandst du es war schön oder also an
sich es war ja ganz schön weil das habe
ich noch gar nicht thematisiert schöner
Ort nur es war halt sehr ausgestorben ne
ich muss auch sagen also wenn man sich
jetzt vorstellt dass da ein paar Leute
rumlaufen ist die Szenerie eigentlich in
Ordnung sieht schon nett aus aber ich
bin jetztich schon auf Krakau ich habe
jetzt keine hohen Ansprüche für heute
aber wir schauen einfach mal was hier
heute geht das ist mein Outfit was ich
mir heute im zerra geholt habe für den
Winter also weil hier ist es jetzt nicht
so warm ab auf der Piste jetzt hier aber
zack zack wir sind jetzt auf jeden Fall
auf dem Weg in die Altstadt da hinten
soll vi los sein und Tristan glaubt mir
nicht man hört schon da hinten wo die
Kirche ist du glaubst mir nicht dass wir
heute noch einen coolen Abend haben
werden ich weiß aber mit all meiner
Reiseerfahrung aus den letzten Monaten
kann ich dir versichern hier geht was ja
in sada das war da war nichts los da
hast du Recht aber das habe ich auch
nicht versichert so das sieht do schon
mal viel besser aus und da sind schon
die ersten unterwegs sind geil e aber
sieht echt nice aus oder guck mal hier
sind überall noch Bars die Leute sind
hier noch draußen
[Musik]
so und jetzt haben wir hier einub neben
nächsten da ist der erste da sind noch
andere habe ich doch gesagt war noch
nicht drin ja
stimmt und was sagst
[Musik]
du es ist genauso wie in Danzig du gehst
hier die Straße runter und überall
kommen Leute auf dich zu und wollen
nicht irgendwie so
re und die sind richtig
penetrant und damit einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen aus dem sonnigen Krakau
geil die Sonne scheint wir haben fast
20° wir haben heute auf jeden Fall schön
ausgeschlafen und jetzt geht's erstmal
in die Krakau Altstadt wo wir gestern
auch schon waren und was leckeres
frühstücken mal gucken wir schauen uns
ein bisschen Krak an bevor es dann um
18:55 Uhr weiter geheht nach
Griechenland und zwar tessaloniki Tag
wird sicherlich genau so anstrengend
gestern aber nicht lang labern let's
go
[Musik]
so jetzt gibt's erstmal hier ein
leckeres Frühstück ich hoffe schmeckt
Kaffee hat aber sehr sehr gute Bewertung
und ja die Sonne scheint ist es ziemlich
heiß mit
Pulli also wir philosophieren gerade
noch mal über den letzten Abend
eigentlich war es echt lustig aber wir
wurden wirklich also ich würde mal
schätzen 25 mal von verschiedenen Leuten
gefragt ob wir irgendwelche stripl
lokale wollen also das ist hier völlig
aus dem Ruder geraten glaube ich mit
diesen ganzen Strip Dingern wä das
wenigstens was gewesen was uns
interessiert hätte ne ja eben nee aber
natürlich weiß ich ja schon durch euch
auch dass das alles Abzocke ist und dass
ich da nicht reingehen würde also man
konnte mal einmal durch so ein Fenster
da Luken und das da alles andere als
seriös aus und dann sind wir da
natürlich auch nicht reinspaziert aber
das ist schon echt verrückt was was hier
so abgeht in Krakau danzicher auch das
wird ja eigentlich denke ich in allen
polnischen Städten so sein und wir haben
auch mit einem von diesem Promotern
geredet und der meinte er macht das er
studiert nicht weil das halt wirklich
gut bezahlt ist Leute wir spielen gerade
WWI Millionär und ich bin der Gast Tran
ist qum li einmal noch mal die Frage vor
auf welche Berufsgruppe bezog sich die
Redensart mit allen Wassern gewaschen
ursprünglich a Bierbrauer B Gerber C
Seeleute oder D Goldsucher Seeleute ja
komm dann dann Seeleute sag ich Seeleute
C und richtig welche dieser Sängerin
wurde am weitesten nördlich geboren a
rihan b Beyonce C Jennifer Lopez oder D
Mary s keine Ahnung muss ich raten oder
kann ich jetzt auch die die 125 000
mitnehmen nee ne das macht ja keinen
Sinn das W bei bei dann rate ich einfach
mal am weitesten
nördlichiten sag ich mal Miley Cyrus
also bist du sicher nee überhaupt nicht
Jen Jennifer Lopez ja okay ja aber hat
Spaß gemacht danke dir gucken uns jetzt
noch ein bisschen krako an hier sieht's
genauso aus wie in Rotenburg ob der
Tauber falls ihr euch noch an mein Video
mit der random Postl zah erinnern könnt
da bin ich ja auch oben über die
Stadtmauer gerannt und das sieht
eigentlich eins zu eins gleich aus ja
gut Stadtmauern sind ja auch
wahrscheinlich überall ähnlich
gewesen aber man muss sagen Krakau hat
wirklich eine sehr sehr schöne Altstadt
hier ist einiges los schöne alte
renovierte Häuser gutes Essen und
natürlich ist es an der Stelle manchmal
ein bisschen schade dass wir nur so kurz
hier sind weil man in der kurzen Zeit ja
längst nicht alles entdeckt kan
eigentlich viel zu wenig ne aber so ist
schon mal das
Format Leute tristan ist gerade neben
anem Supermarkt und holt uns ein
bisschen Wasser und wir waren ja in
Thailand zusammen unterwegs und waren
dort jeden Tag bei der Teilmassage ich
glaube es wä lustig wenn wir uns hier
jetzt auch Thai und B massag also das
bevor es jetzt gleich nämlich zum
Flughafen geht will ich da noch
reingehen und ehrlich jetzt also ich war
dabei ich l ein
Thailand ja da bist am grinsen so hier
gab jetzt ein Tee für uns wir haben
draußen genommen im Garten hier kann man
sich jetzt auf jeden Fall eine Massage
aussuchen wenn man unterwegs ist muss
man auch mal ein bisschen abschalten
deswegen gönnen wir uns das auch mal
heute schön als Abschluss in
Krakau und war gut traumhaft traumhaft
trumha ich fand's auch so geil vor allem
wenn man das so lange nicht gemacht hat
dann weiß man erstmal also wenn man das
jeden Tag macht dann ist es irgendwann
so ja ist trotzdem cool und sehr
entspannt aber wenn man es lange nicht
hatte so eine richtige Massage dann ist
viel besser also noch mal viel krasser
ne ja wirklich sehr sehr entspannt ich
muss nur sagen ich würde jetzt lieber an
so einem Strand rauskommen anstatt hier
auf dieser Straße aber man kann ja nicht
alles haben ne wir müssen bald noch mal
nach Thailand okay Leute weiter geht's
zum Flughafen wir haben jetzt 16:30 Uhr
unser Flug heute ist um 18:55 Uhr kurzes
fahzit zu Krakau ja gut allgemein viel
haben wir jetzt nicht gesehen aber die
Massage war gut gestern Abend hatten wir
auch Spaß also rund um ich glaube so ein
Wochenendtrip in Krakau da kann man
einiges erleben in sehr kurze Zeit
deswegen auch hier diese Stadt kann ich
euch empfehlen weiter geht's Leute und
ich weiß dass dieses Video jetzt schon
30 Minuten lang ist ihr wollt ja immer
dass ich alles möglichst reinschneide
und nicht viel rauskatte sonst hätte ich
jetzt ein Video aus diesem vier Parts
gemacht aber ich glaube ich mache zwei
Videos raus und das nächste wird
hoffentlich auch wieder eine halbe
Stunde checkt auf jeden Fall Monopoly go
ab geiles Spiel spielen wir jetzt auch
gleich wieder in der Lounge jetzt geht's
in die nächste Flughafen Lounge vielen
Dank an monopolly GO fürs sponsn des
Videos Daumen nach oben abonnieren für
weitere reisevideos und ja Leute haut
rein ciao